>> Tucker: THEY ARE ALWAYS
AFTERSHOCKS IN CAMPAIGNS, THE
FIRST AFTER THE 2018 MAIN TERMS
OF ARRIVED QUICKLY THIS
AFTERNOON, THE PRESIDENT FIRED
HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL, JEFF
SESSIONS.
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR, HE HAS
PUBLICLY CRITICIZED AND
RIDICULED JEFF SESSIONS, SO IT
IS NOT SURPRISING.
REPLACING SESSIONS WITH A NEW
APPOINTMENT, REPUBLICANS HELD
THE SENATE, CLEARLY SAW NO
REASON TO KEEP HIM AROUND.
IN THEORY, GOING FORWARD, JEFF
SESSIONS COULD CHALLENGE DOUG
JONES IN 2020 TO RECLAIM THE
ALABAMA SENATE SEE THAT HE GAVE
UP TO SERVE THE PRESIDENT AS AG.
IF HE DID THAT, HE WOULD ALMOST
CERTAINLY WIN, ONE OF THE MOST
POPULAR PEOPLE IN THE STATE.
WE ASKED A SOURCE CLOSE TO
SESSION, SAID THAT WOULD
PROBABLY NOT HAPPEN AND HE
WOULD RETIRE INTO PRIVATE LIFE
HE DOES NOT COME OF COURSE, WE
WILL WISH HIM THE BEST, BUT IT
WILL BE, AND WE SHOULD SAY THIS,
A LOSS FOR THE COUNTRY.
DONALD TRUMP'S LONG SHOT
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN SUCCEEDED
BECAUSE HE PROMISED WHAT SO MANY
VOTERS WANTED, AND YET WHAT SO
FEW POLITICIANS WERE WILLING TO
CAMPAIGN ON, BECAUSE THEY ARE
COWARDS.
AMONG HIS MANY PROMISES, THE
MOST IMPORTANT WAS HIS PLEDGE TO
REVERSE DECADES OF DELIBERATE
NEGLECT AND TREAT OUR NATIONAL
BORDERS LIKE THEY ARE REAL, LIKE
ALL COUNTRY MATTERS.
NOBODY UNDERSTOOD THAT MESSAGE
BETTER THAN JEFF SESSIONS.
HE UNDERSTOOD IT IMMEDIATELY.
HE WAS ONE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
FIRST AND MOST UNWAVERING
SUPPORTERS, I THINK THE FIRST IN
THE SENATE, AND IT WAS BECAUSE
OF IMMIGRATION.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT TOOK OFFICE,
HE GAVE UP AND ESSENTIALLY
LIFETIME POST REPRESENTING
ALABAMA TO HELP FULFILL TRUMP'S
MISSION.
SADLY, THE COUNTRY WAS GOING
ANOTHER WAY.
WITHIN ABOUT 5 MINUTES, THE 2016
ELECTION, THE DEMOCRATS DECIDED
IT WAS NOT ABOUT IMMIGRATION OR
AN ABANDONED MIDDLE-CLASS, BUT
RATHER ABOUT "RUSSIA!"
AND THE CONSPIRACY BETWEEN
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND TRUMP.
NOW, REPUBLICAN SAID THEY DIDN'T
BELIEVE THAT STORY, AND YET FOR
SOME REASON, MANY OF THEM ALLOW
DEMOCRATS TO REFRAME THE ENTIRE
POLITICAL DEBATE IN THE COUNTRY
AND MAKE RUSSIA THE SINGLE
BIGGEST ISSUE IN AMERICAN
POLITICS.
BUT JEFF SESSIONS DID NOT FALL
FOR THAT, HE NEVER LET HIMSELF
GET DISTRACTED FROM THE MISSION
AT HAND, EVERYONE ELSE OBSESSED
OVER DOSSIERS AND FISA WARRANTS,
SESSIONS WORRIED ABOUT THE
MISSION HE WAS HIRED TO DO.
HE INTRODUCED A ZERO-TOLERANCE
APPROACH TO IMMIGRATION
PROSECUTION, TREATED ILLEGAL
ENTRY INTO THE UNITED STATES AS
A CRIME, BECAUSE IT IS A CRIME.
HE'S AT DOJ ISSUED A NEW
OPINIONS AND TO RESTRICT THE
EXPLOITATION OF ASYLUM LAWS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
HE FOUGHT TO STRIP AGILE FUNDING
OF SANCTUARY CITIES.
COURTS RULED AGAINST HIM, BUT HE
DID EVERYTHING HE COULD TO GET
THOSE THINGS DONE.
HIS DEPARTMENT ACCELERATED THE
HIRING OF IMMIGRATION JUDGES,
DIDN'T GET A LOT OF ATTENTION,
BUT A BIG DEAL.
THEY CAN TAKE LACE MORE QUICKLY.
A SERVICE TO AMERICA AND FOR THE
PEOPLE BEING HELD.
ON DHAKA, IS IT REFUTABLE TO
DEFEND THAT PROGRAM, WHICH IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, REALLY INDUCED
THE PRESIDENT TO ENTER THE
PROGRAM.
SESSIONS WASN'T JUST A FACT
EVENT IMMIGRATION, THOUGH, HE
ROLLED BACK THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION'S SOFT ON CRIME
POLICIES ACROSS THE BOARD
APPEARED HE PURSUED TOUGHER
PENALTIES FOR DRUG DEALERS,
NOT JUST FOR LIBERALS, BUT
WEALTHY LIBERTARIANS, WHO
DECIDED THE WAR ON DRUGS WAS A
TOTAL DISASTER.
THIS AT A TIME WHEN MORE PEOPLE
ARE DYING EVERY YEAR OF DRUG
ODs AND THEN DIED IN ALL OF
VIETNAM PAIRED WITH A DECADENT
DECIDED IT IS IMMORAL TO
PROSECUTE DRUG      DRUG DEALERS
PROSECUTE DRUG      DRUG DEALER.
OF COURSE, SESSIONS ALMOST ENDED
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION'S
HARASSMENT OR LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THAT HELPED
DRIVE A SURGE IN VIOLENT CRIME
IN MAJOR CITIES.
IF YOU LIVE IN ONE, YOU KNOW
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
PASSIONS IT DID ALL OF THIS,
EVEN AS HE FINDS IT APPOINTED
HIM ATTACKED HIM IN PUBLIC,
THE ATTACKS STARTED MORE THAN A
YEAR AGO AFTER ONE OF THE
RESIDENTS PUBLIC DATE REBUKES,
WE TRAVELED WITH HIM TO
EL SALVADOR WHERE HE WAS PUSHING
A FIGHT AGAINST MS-13.
SESSIONS MADE IT CLEAR HE WAS
THERE TO GET RESULTS AND WOULD
SERVE AS LONG AS THE PRESIDENT
WOULD HAVE HIM.
>> HE HASN'T SAID AGAIN AND
AGAIN IN MANY DIFFERENT FORMS
OUT THIS BARRAGE THAT YOU SHOULD
NOT HAVE RECUSED YOURSELF FROM
OVERSIGHT IN A RUSH
INVESTIGATION PAIR DO YOU AGREE
WITH THAT?
>> I UNDERSTAND HIS FEELINGS
ABOUT IT.
BECAUSE THIS HAS BEEN A BIG
DISTRACTION FOR HIM.
BUT TUCKER, I THOUGHT THE
EXPERTS IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, THE PEOPLE WHO TRAINED
IN THAT, I'M CONFIDENT I MADE
THE RIGHT DECISION.
TO SPEAK THE USE OF THE
CRITICISM WAS HURTFUL AND THE
PRESIDENT HAS MADE IT REALLY
CLEAR THAT HE DOESN'T SEEM TO
WANT YOU TO RUN FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WILL YOU CONTINUE TO RUN IT?
>> HE CAN MAKE THAT CLEAR AT ANY
TIME, I SERVE AT THE PLEASURE OF
THE PRESIDENT.
IF HE WANTS TO MAKE A CHANGE, HE
CAN CERTAINLY DO SO, AND I WOULD
BE GLAD TO YIELD IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE, NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: SESSIONS WASN'T
PERFECT, OBVIOUSLY, HE SOMETIMES
GOT ROLLED BY HIS STAFF.
THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATIONS HAVE
SHOWED THAT FBI AND DOJ ARE
DEEPLY POLITICIZED.
SESSIONS NEVER SEEMED TO FULLY
GET A HANDLE ON THE PERMANENT
BUREAUCRACY BENEATH THEM.
BUT IF YOU TAKE THREE STEPS
BACK, HERE IS WHAT YOU SEE.
IN AN ADMINISTRATION BESET WITH
CONSTANT LEAKS AND INFIGHTING
AND PEOPLE LOOKING OUT FOR
THEMSELVES AND ONLY THEMSELVES,
SESSIONS WITH MAYBE ONE OF THE
VERY FEW PEOPLE WHO NEVER FORGOT